hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter five of the categories
Aristotle is going to give us a much
more in-depth examination of substance
and one of the key ideas or rather
distinction that he's going to make
which which has a lot of implications
that he draws out is that between what
he calls primary and secondary
substances so the term substance is
Lucia and primary and secondary pretty
straightforward in the Greek prose I do
that I just means first and second right
so he says that some substances some you
see I deserve the the name or the the
notion we could say of substance much
more than others do and it's sort of
jump ahead and you know give you like a
summary right up front there's
individual things like human being or
horse or Tai and then there are the
classes which Aristotle calls species
and genera these are actually coming
from Latin terms in a spec AIDS and
gayness which are translating a dose and
gayness and these these are going to be
used quite a bit
so another thing I want to specify from
the beginning in this little discussion
is whatever notion you are bringing to
the table about species and genus coming
from classification of animals or plants
or something like that put that out of
your mind for the time being that won't
be helpful here in part because
Aristotle is using it as part of a
classic Atari hierarchy but he's not
doing so in exactly the same way as
natural history does that that were
introduced to in like earth science or
things like that so what does Aristotle
have to say
she begins by saying what most deserves
to be called substance is what is
neither predicated neither said he's
using the verb there lagging right to
say to speak neither predicated of a
subject nor in a subject if and by the
way if this distinction is throwing you
I've done another discussion of that so
you should look at that video before you
go into this one so what is neither
predicated of a subject neither said of
some subject nor in another subject much
much later he will specify as well hey
remember that in the subject does not
mean present as a part of a subject like
organs are like shoulder elbow in our
body because then people might say well
those aren't really substances don't
worry about that so much at this point
think in terms of what he's talking
about individual human being individual
horse individual piece of chalk right
those are substances those you don't say
the individual piece of chalk is in a
subject it is a subject other things are
in it like the whiteness or the hardness
those qualities right which are actually
essential qualities to it I believe well
maybe not what you talk comes in a
number number of different colors
in any case we have primary substance
alright and then we're going to have
secondary substances and he's going to
say you know we can talk about those as
being substance in a derivative way in a
way that is connected to actual
substance so he says we do speak of
secondary substances those within which
being species the primary or first are
included and those within which being
genera the species themselves are
contained so this is a very important
way of thinking about species and genera
are in some respects relational terms
and you could have a number of different
genera stacked up quite high in actual
practice Aristotle doesn't go quite so
far with that for example we'll take you
know human being I am a human being
presumably you're a human being unless
you know helium's are watching this
somewhere which I suppose could happen
someday
but let's assume you're a human being so
human being individual human being on
your end human being on my end
we are primary substances both you and I
are human beings and there is a species
human being we use the same word to
describe that you know we we apply that
and we're part of a class that is what
Aristotle calls a species now the the
species human being is part of a larger
genera and what is that genera or what
is the genus rather what is that genus
that is animal now I know that we would
break it down we'd say well we're in the
family of hominids and those are part of
you know eight or whatever whatever we
classify ourselves into I'm a little bit
hazy on that and then those would be
mammals and that animals way way up
there that's fine then you just have
more genera stacked up on top of each
other the basic idea is
this the species is the first thing
removed from primary substance it's the
secondary substance that encompasses
individual things of that kind
whatever else you place above that is a
zag a nose and and that has multiple
species within it we could do this with
tools as well right our classification
we have an individual hammer and then
another individual hammer and they don't
look exactly the same but they're part
of the species hammer which we ourselves
have perhaps come up with I don't really
know exactly how Aristotle would
classify this probably he would say you
know it is there's this some sort of
species that is somewhat natural but
it's also somewhat artificial and then
we could put it into the you know genera
of tools or instruments or whatever else
we want to call it you see we can do
this with lots of things chalk right
we'll use that as an example again I
have three pieces of chalk in my hand
you see them right there they are all
within the species of chalk and they are
individual things as well so we have
primary substance secondary substance
then moving on a little bit in the
conception of this like I put here on
the board Aristotle talks about the name
and the definition of predicates and
this might seem a little bit confusing
too so let's actually go over this a
little bit closely says it's plain that
the name and the definition of the
predicate can both be affirmed of the
subject so what with the example here we
predicate man of an individual man as
the subject we also take the name of the
species man and we assert it of each
individual or again to use the example
of chalk right predicating this means
we're saying of something so we
predicate the
the name chalk of all these pieces of
chalk and we can add as many as we like
the species can encompass perhaps
infinite numbers the now the definition
if we know something about the species
right think about a definition not in
terms of a dictionary definition but
defining the what that thing in the
accents of it the definition is a
statement of the being or the essence of
the thing the substance so he says there
we go
yeah the tome logo is the definition in
this case so we might say the account
the explanation the the describing what
the thing is those can be predicated as
a subject so if you know something
before you actually see any real chalk
let's say somebody was able to give you
something like a real definition of
chalk not something contingent like what
I write on the chalkboard with right but
rather something that told you about the
what what this stuff is in its being
then you would be able to apply that to
the individual pieces of choice that
might actually help you recognize what
that thing is when you encounter it oh
that's a piece of truck I know because I
have learned about that species at a
certain point we might sit about various
animal species you've never seen a
badger right but you you go and you you
learned about badgers and then you you
run into one you reckon oh that there's
a badger right or you're looking in you
know the forest and you happen to see
some apple mint and you recognize the
shape of something minty and you go up
to it you brush against that you're like
that smells very different aha I've
heard of that this is an individual
substance this is an instance of the
species Apple mint so he talks about the
name of the definition of predicates
what would predicates be species and
genera are things that are predicated of
first substance what else though he adds
to this when we come to things which are
present are found in a subject
remember that's part of what makes a
substance of substance that other things
can be present or found in it we cannot
at least in most cases affirm or
predicate of of that subject so the
definition itself will in no case
whatever apply for example knowledge
right knowledge is in a subject in in
our minds but we can use the word for
example let's say I know I know grammar
right or let's say philosophy right I
understand philosophy whatever
philosophy happens to be I want to get
away from the grammar example for a bit
that's knowledge that's in in my head
and you can use a derivative term
philosopher of me the individual
substance but you cannot simply you know
predicate the philosophy in my head of
me right it is a different type of
relation predication and being in a
subject so he take this as white right
we can take white as an example white is
no doubt in a body and thus is affirmed
of a body for a body of course it's
called white but the definition of white
of the color that is that we call white
can't be predicated of any body
whatsoever that's the definition of the
color but not of the bodies that contain
the color hopefully you understand that
distinction now he also talks about
another important thing primary
substances because they are subjects are
what allow anything to exist or to have
being he Aristotle will go out and say
you know if there weren't primary
substances
then there wouldn't be anything that
could be in a substance right so no
human beings or other intelligent beings
no knowledge because there's nothing for
them to be in if there's no things that
are written upon there's no writing
right you know we could go on and on and
on with examples of this now why is this
important in terms of primary and
secondary substances
well this implies that without
individual things there are no species
or genera as substances secondary
substances only have their being as
secondary substances because of the
existence of the primary substances the
subjects that they are the species or
genera of so no human being no species
of human being now you might say well
that doesn't make any sense what if we
you know just kill looks like what the
dodo right
perhaps we you know still classify
things as the dodo bird even we think
even though we think that all of them
have been killed off yes you're right we
do have something like a mental
construct and we can even like you know
look at the DNA sequence of extinct
creatures and all that sort of stuff but
that is not the same thing as what
Aristotle is calling a species that's
something that describes the species it
might even be part of it its definition
as he's calling it or account but it's
not the species itself so hopefully that
clears that up now another thing that he
says that's really interesting is that
species is better called substance than
is genus why because species is closer
to the individual things as a matter of
fact Aristotle will go on to say in that
discussion that individual things to
species
have the same sort of relation as
species do two genera so think of
species as being like classes of things
and then genera as being higher level
classes of classes so why is the species
you know more substance than the genesis
well not only is it closer it's also
more informative as aristotle says if
somebody asks you well what is this
thing that you're looking at right here
that's talking to you on this video
he said well an animal that's not very
descriptive okay it is true I'm an
animal but that doesn't tell you an
awful lot about what this thing is and
so Aristotle says man or human being is
a much better descriptor it's it's more
informative it tells you more we might
say in our contemporary parlance it
conveys more information about the thing
the last thing that I want to say here
about this distinction between primary
and secondary substances is that
Aristotle stress is that a primary
substance denotes a unity there is some
sort of one thing right we could have a
number of different primary substances
but they're all each one thing so again
the truck right this piece of chalk is
not this piece of chalk there's not a
hell of a lot going on with chalk right
there's not a lot of you know great
information to convey there it's not
like human being or something like that
but they're not the same we put them
together and now we have a many right
secondary substances are by their very
nature a many or a multitude I suppose
the only possible case in which that
would not be the case would be if there
was only one piece of chalk left in the
universe or one human being in the
universe in which case the genus not the
genus of species and the individual
would essentially you know be the same
thing but but it but they're not so
because an individual human thing is not
the same thing as the species you
being at least we could conceive of
other human beings existing or we could
remember that they had existed in in the
past so hopefully that helps you
understand this this relationship
between what Aristotle is calling
primary substances and secondary
substances individual things that exist
and the classes the the species and
genera that associates or or or collect
up those